to join the conversation like us on
facebook at c-span history
each week american history tv's real
america brings you public affairs films
from the 20th century
nine from little rock is a 1964 u.s
information agency film narrated by
jefferson thomas one of the nine
african-american students who in 1957
enrolled in little rock arkansas's
all-white central high school
arkansas's governor prevented the
students from attending classes until
president eisenhower sent 1 000 u.s army
troops and federalized the 10 000 strong
arkansas national guard to restore order
and enforce school desegregation
in the film mr thomas and several other
of the little rock nine reflect on their
experience life beyond high school and
hopes for the future the film won an
academy award in 1965 for documentary
short subject
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
where do you begin
where do you look
[Music]
like an ancient battlefield the ground
is silent though people still move in
familiar places
now in this field negro and white run
together remembering not how it was in
little rock arkansas in 1957
perhaps it is best for those today to
look where they are going and not where
they have been
[Music]
but when you're a dark man in a country
where the negro is demanding more and
more an equal chance
you have the right to look back to
discover if you are really moving
forward or if the world is just moving
beneath your feet
[Music]
i have a special reason for looking back
my name is jefferson thomas
and i'm one of the nine from little rock
[Music]
there is nothing strange in seeing nine
american children walking to school on a
september morning but this was a special
morning in a special part of america
a place where negro children had never
gone to school with whites before
[Music]
hatred is easier to organize than
understanding and there was a minority
in our state who found it to their
advantage to bring hate to little rock
in 1957.
while we watched the white children went
to school
and we stood outside
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
we had been taught in school that we
were a nation under law
and the law said segregation was wrong
now we waited to see if our laws had
meaning
or were just words in a book
or idle talk in a classroom
on september 27 1957 president
eisenhower sent 1 000 men of the united
states army to carry out the law
[Music]
the supreme court of the united states
had said
the entire strength of the nation may be
used to enforce in any part of the land
the security of all rights entrusted by
the constitution
and that included my rights and the
rights of eight other negro americans
who wanted to go to central high school
in little rock arkansas
we were terence roberts
thelma mothershed
elizabeth eckford ernest green
colotta walls melba patillo
minijean brown and gloria ray
and we were going to school again
obviously in this town of a hundred
thousand there were many who didn't like
what was happening
but as we looked at the soldiers we knew
there must be millions of others who
thought we represented something
important
[Music]
when the doors closed behind us that day
it was both an end
and a beginning
from that moment on we would be watched
not only by those who looked at us as
strangers but by those who wondered if
we would live up to our new opportunity
i remember standing there wondering how
history would judge us
[Music]
it's been seven years since that first
day
what has happened
where have we gone
what have we done
[Applause]
i was the oldest of the nine
and perhaps the least serious
i came here to southern illinois
university after graduation
at first i thought i wanted to be a
nurse but i was too outgoing for that
now i know i want to work in a newspaper
to be a journalist and to write
more than anything else in the world i
want to write
this year i took a job in the university
newspaper
i work as a reporter
20 hours a week after classes
there's no substitute for writing under
pressure to have to get the story out
and to make it good
i remember the reporters who came from
all over the world to cover the story of
little rock
to be able to take a story like that and
to put it into words
is something i've always wanted to be
able to do
someday i'm going to write a book about
what happened in little rock
but first i've got to learn more about
writing and about the world
and you can do that best in school
teachers like professor simon have
helped me to grow up
he's a man who makes you want to go to
school forever
but i'm going to work after i graduate
i've applied to two newspapers and one
is already offering me a job
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm going to miss this university
the friendships i have made here are
long and deep
[Music]
the things i have learned here have
helped me to come to terms with myself
[Music]
for the first time in my life i have
begun to understand why some americans
act the way they do
[Music]
i know now some americans have a fear of
the negro
a fear born of a way of life that has
been dead in this country since the end
of slavery
that's what the mob in little rock was
afraid of
with the negro who had done so much with
no chance
might do so much more with an equal one
[Music]
okay
it's been four years since i stood in
this hallway and watched the faces
moving from class to class
none of this would seem strange to us
now for we all went on to colleges where
there were more whites than negroes
except elizabeth
she went to central state college in
ohio
[Applause]
central state was founded as an all
negro college about a hundred years ago
today like most american schools it is a
mixture of negro and white
when i entered high school i thought i
wanted to be a lawyer and then a teacher
and now like most students i haven't
quite decided what i want to be
the world is a big place
and when i go out into it i want to be
sure i go in the right direction
[Music]
if it hadn't been for that morning in
september 1957
i could have gone into law or education
and not thought much about it
i was frightened that morning
[Music]
but i learned a great deal about people
not only about the people who were there
but about the people who were not there
like the politician who encouraged the
mob
like the thousands who suffered with me
and wrote to me to tell me so
while i waited
i heard brave horses speak out against
intolerance and i saw grown men turn
their heads in shame from a camera
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
central state is the negro college that
opened its doors to whites only 17 years
ago
today
20 of the student body and faculty are
white
and there are still negroes who are
against integration
[Applause]
the negro is like most americans
possessing no monopoly on tolerance
and hoping that the fuel the uninformed
will not be confused with the rest of us
[Music]
four years ago a negro walked this hall
in fear
some of the hate outside had come inside
and there were a few who tried to impose
their will on the mini
when we went up a stairway we hung on to
the railing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
can i help you
uh
i'm looking for miss poindexter's room
she's in room 214.
thank you very much
anytime
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thelma used to say the problems we had
getting into this school were worth it
just to be able to take courses from
some of the teachers
it's not surprising so many students
like thelma wanted to go into teaching
[Music]
i graduate this year from southern
illinois university at carbondale
going to college is a tradition in my
family that's why i applied for central
i wanted a good high school education
i wanted the best training i could get
before i entered college
aspirations are very personal things
but i think i can state mine simply
i love to teach and i love children
children are happy moody
difficult and wonderful
they accept me for what i am
after i finish college i want to apply
for job teaching in little rock
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe someday at central high
i wonder what it'll be like
[Music]
carlotta and i had missed done
none of us had seen a school with so
much equipment before
i think it was the equipment that first
gave ernie the impression he wanted to
be an engineer
but i'm glad he changed his mind
after i leave michigan state university
i'm going to work in the field of civil
rights as a leader and an organizer
even in the northern states you'll find
pockets of discrimination like you do
all over the world
but there's a tide rising against it and
i want to be part of it
[Music]
we got to hold
[Applause]
i came to michigan state to study
engineering three years ago i changed my
mind
i decided i would rather work with
people than with machines
under professor david gottlieb i receive
my bachelor's degree in sociology
next week i will receive my master's
i'm convinced that a white american can
never fully understand what motivates
the negro's desire for equality
but the white american is becoming more
concerned especially my generation and
that makes tomorrow
worth dreaming about
the american negro must protest and he
must also build understanding by
searching for the truth
[Music]
the tools for truth and science are now
becoming tools for truth and human
relations
for the past two years i have been
compiling data on the aspirations of
negro and white children in a segregated
community
today we are capable of getting answers
that have real meaning that carry the
power of fact against those who exploit
rumor and prejudice
[Music]
my research is just one part in a quiet
revolution that's taking place in
america
it's not alone a revolution in
technology but a revolution in thinking
a revolution that says man no matter how
humble his birth
what color his skin must be permitted to
go as far as his mind and his
aspirations will take him
[Music]
ernie was the first of us to graduate
from central
colorado and i were the last
we were the class of 1960.
colorado goes to denver university in
colorado
she's a good student and she likes the
high mountains out there
gloria ray is a senior at the illinois
institute of technology
this year she receives her degree in
chemistry
terence roberts is studying for his
degree in business administration at the
city college of los angeles
[Music]
melba patello as we guessed married
early
she wasn't in college over a year before
she became a housewife
[Music]
[Applause]
and me
this spring i take an exam to become a
certified public accountant
that means i'm supposed to be qualified
to keep track of profits and losses
i'm not sure i know enough yet to say
what all this adds up to
i haven't counted all the victory since
that first day we went to school here
but i know there's been at least
nine
[Music]
in little rock there's a slow bridge
taking shape over that chasm of
intolerance and ignorance
it's a bridge that's going to be built
by us and by our children
before it's finished we're going to have
our problems
but if little rock taught nothing more
it taught all americans that problems
can make us better
much better
[Music]
foreign